La huge announcement I am shooting my
special Wednesday December 14th here in
Los Angeles at the dynasty typewriter
theater go to ryansickler.com for
tickets use code sickler you're gonna
get half off tickets all right please
come out I want the place packed we're
doing two shows and uh I want all the
die hards there all right screw the
industry this is for the fans go to
ryansickler.com get your tickets today
Grand Rapids I'll see you all December
9th and 10th get your tickets to those
shows and all shows on my website at
ryansickler.com
[Music]
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the how do you do y'all
we are over here doing it in the night
past Studios I am Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social media and I just want to say as I
say every week thank you thank you very
much
for however you support this show
however you support me it does not go
unnoticed I genuinely appreciate it
um if you want to make a difference an
easy free one then hit subscribe on that
YouTube channel you know what I'm saying
you're watching just hit it it makes a
big difference in our world and if you
gotta have more honeydew then you got to
check out the patreon it's the wildest
show on patreon it's called the Honeydew
with y'all and I'm highlighting the low
lights with y'all and y'all have stories
that
I still have nightmares about alright so
it is five dollars a month uh if you
sign up for a year you get over a month
free and you're getting a honeydew a day
earlier getting it ad free and it's no
additional cost it's not all these
layers and whatever it's five bucks okay
tears whatever and if I'm in your town
when you're around come out and see me
on tour
um I'll be in Chicago November 11th and
12th in Grand Rapids December 9th and
the 10th that's the biz now you guys
know what we do over here we highlight
the low lights I always say these are
the stories behind the storytellers I am
very excited to have this Storyteller
back on the Honeydew ladies and
Gentlemen please Welcome Matt wrong or
welcome back thank you Ryan thanks dude
appreciate it thank you for being here
young man that's good by the way thanks
dude you too you too we're aging well
all right I mean I look at pictures of
me when I was younger with a goatee and
I'm like I didn't have one [ __ ]
friend to tell me to shave that off my
[ __ ] face we all did it we all did it
start making really think about who your
friends were in life you know yeah we
really we really all thought we were
friends with Cypress Hillary House of
Pain
like we thought we could go stand with
them I had one for so long I have no
Chin so I had one for so long it was
like my savior yeah so it was strategy
for you oh yeah I just was like I wonder
what this would look like and then I
left it for 10 years yeah yeah well it
also just just hanging out with the
black Puerto Rican guys from New York
when I was in college you know it was
just like this is the look I should
choose shoe polished your beard up and
stuff bring it up way high no you bring
it up real like up here I went I used to
go to uh this barber in the city uh and
and he he
wanted his barber in the city and he
would um he'd you know clean me up and
he just he faded it right in right into
just weird stubble I had once but it was
almost too clean like it was like George
Michael yeah yeah I was just like oh
it's like just not exactly you put that
you put that on on a black gentleman you
put that on a Latin gentleman
excellent on me no or George Michael
looked good too he did he made it work
yeah yeah looked like Chrome
um all right well before we get into
anything speaking of work let's talk
about you have a new special coming out
let's talk about your work okay and it's
called Doug it's named after a horrible
guy I met on vacation I think all of us
uh dudes need we need bad examples you
know we need like we we've had good ones
and we need those two even more but I
think at least once your life you got to
meet someone that you're like [ __ ] that
I cannot be you man I just can't can I
ask you
um
like first of all as a comedian as a
performer obviously whatever you're
choosing you want it to it makes it made
an impact on you yes so this guy made
such a negative impact on you that
you're like I'm gonna name this [ __ ]
special after this piece of [ __ ] yeah
what happened it's just it's the story
that I close on and it's got this big
reveal where I bring someone out of the
audience
uh I won't give away the twist but it
was just the whole special encompasses
me having a kid during the pandemic and
bartender talk about yes uh bartending
in Chicago during the pan during my 20s
the pandemic of my life
I know I said in Chicago in the pandemic
and then uh you know just getting
through the that the the story I'm gonna
get with you a little bit and then
culminating in this trip where you know
my wife and I were well it was just like
we weren't married yet but I was like
this is gonna be this is gonna be it and
I'm looking forward to the future maybe
having a kid and I met Doug and his wife
who uh
this isn't giving away any jokes but
every time I saw Doug he was uh wet and
drunk we were in Anguilla What in in the
Caribbean like he woke up in the froth
of the surf with just a half bottle of
Jack that's a great description and he
was they were clearly you never go to
what if somebody's just says imagine
what this person looks like wet never
enters the [ __ ] it up but I don't know
why like where did you come from
I don't remember this made it in the
special but at one point he followed a a
large black gentleman down the beach
insisting that the guy was in the NFL
but he couldn't remember his name and
the guy's like you know thick Patois
like I'm not an NFL man hey you know
like he's just like please please leave
me alone and I'm like just so drunk the
racism is magnified and what it come
down to is him and his wife both uh uh
they were on vacation without their kids
and they they did they weren't like you
go on vacation with your kids you're
like yes right you're like oh but you're
also like
I miss him you know I know I went on the
road and I'm away from Rose I'm just
like
this is good to have this freedom but I
miss you know it's that that's the we
feel lucky they were angry at the fact
that they had kids Furious as if someone
else saying about it when they're not
even there you know yeah
only part I'll do from the bit is by uh
uh his wife you know Doug's wife suck
too so bad I don't remember her name as
I'm sitting here thinking I'm a single
man and Doug's got a Doug's tied down
you know what I'm saying you know
I gotta I understand that maybe the
quality of the person's not that great
but Doug went and did it man Doug found
his he and he it bugs me that he has
like I think that's a cool name every
Doug I've met is Chill like they sell
you weed at a good price not a good
price you know have some with you
no one show up your party yet Doug
doesn't care he's like they're gonna
come man chill and she chill out smoke
some of this you know dogs make lives
better generally this guy suck so Doug's
wife uh my wife was like she have kids
she's like uh yeah and she's like are
they here well he goes are they here and
that's why because no no [ __ ] that [ __ ]
no [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them
what okay all right Mrs Doug you know
and we're both childless we're free as
can be but like just being that having
that moment of like I'm I'm I'm never
gonna like ever sure when my kid gets
into teen years you know and yours as
well I'm sure you'll both of us at
certain points would be like
I can't kill him you know like because
there'll be those moments that crash the
car whatever but like
the hatred the hatred was real they they
talked about their kids the way some
people talk about like their landlords
you know like yeah
you know what you know what he tried
okay
yeah so anyway but yeah but they bonded
over their their love comes from their
probably the hatred of their children I
don't even think they liked each other
no no no I'm trying to I know I'm sorry
to find something and like there were
moments where Doug seemed fun but he was
just he would just get way too drunk way
too fast you know like ever he would I
would see him it was a small Resort he
would be passed out every day you're
saying dude there's this outdoor bar
called Elvis's bar and there's this this
giant uh uh dude uh Caribbean man
pouring drinks he had this big hit this
jar of this this shot that he made that
was like it just burned like gas you
know like oh you know but it was great
like you have to do one of Elvis's shots
and it was in a boat on the sand the
whole bar had like seats built into the
side of the bar that you sit on the boat
it was great and I'd get there at like
nine and Doug's asleep across two of the
chairs and people are like taking
pictures with him and [ __ ] and I'm just
like
Doug again
and his wife is just like look at this
all these pictures were taken with him
yeah avoid Doug man you need help
all right so where can we find the
special okay so that you had to ask
about Doug yeah yeah so the specialist
going uh exclusively to moment house
which is a thing uh September 15th it'll
go up for pre-sale it'll be five bucks
and then uh September uh 16th it'll be
you know uh the regular price which it's
somewhere between five and ten I forget
what it is but anyway it's just it's a
special that I had the hour ready to go
at the beginning of 2020. we all know
what happened all the penis joke
Emporium shut down across the country so
it's like there's no shooting specials
people didn't feel comfortable I wasn't
going to pack a house and be like you
love me though right let's get sick yeah
so I I was like okay let's let's shelve
it and I had to wait a year and by then
I'd had a kid and you know did this trip
I'm gonna talk about with you and then
like I just I uh half that material I
just threw out and like
wrote from there so it's this and it's
got this big twist ending that I mean I
took it I let some networks look at it
and got some offers but I was just like
I don't I want this to be more of an
event like I want this thing to be
because it's got this revealed at the
end that I did on the road and people
would film it and put it up on Instagram
and I have to be like and I'd be like
please take this down and they would
uh and thankfully it was no one who had
a massive following that blew this thing
for me but you know I
from then on the months leading up to
the special I was like do not film this
you know or or don't tell people how
this goes kind of thing because it it's
almost like a magic trick so I'm trying
to make this thing you know it's up for
two weeks you can watch it anytime
during those two weeks and download it
and I just I want it to be like a thing
where people are gonna watch it with
with friends almost like remember when
you were a kid and someone would get
like my Dad's getting the Tyson fight
yeah you're like let's go and there was
nowhere to sit like everyone's just
asses and elbows like I want I want to
give that kind of feel where it's kind
of like it's up for a limited time let's
do that it's one of those things I'm
just trying because I think the special
Market is beyond glutted you know what I
mean like it has been forever and that's
fine that just means there's variety uh
I don't I'm not gonna sit here and act
like uh I'm gonna get the kind of uh
reaction to my special that because
Andrew Schultz did the same thing you
know and made like a million dollars
Shameless a million dollars and then
took it down and then put it back up and
did a video that was like I just love
money sorry and I'm just like good for
you dude you know but I'm like all right
I'll I'll follow that I'll try I'll try
to I'll try to do that same kind of
thing because I mean that guy knows what
he's doing yeah [ __ ] yeah you know what
I mean so I'm just like it's kind of
nice to not have to dance the dance you
know like I I remember talking I thank
them at the comedy so I was like I
appreciate you guys like him and Segura
and these guys all Paving the way for
everybody putting it out there showing
you that it works it's a tried and true
method you don't have to [ __ ] fail
with these [ __ ] got all the
money let them [ __ ] tell us what
works you know what I mean that do work
no don't waste that 20 grand okay thank
you dude I had a podcast that was doing
like whatever numbers and I just stopped
because I'm just like this is this is
stalled I put everything into this for
two years cool let me focus on my social
media you know my social media since
then has doubled which is great but it's
like I I like here here's in a nutshell
I remember someone uh was David Angelo
in New York he I think he had like a
razor blade company that he started
something and he said someone else was
it was saying to him like oh I'm gonna
see if I can get an ad on Tim Dillon's
podcast and David Angelo's like you're
gonna have to pay and he gave him a
figure for a for like a a red ad that I
was like I was like good for Tim you
[ __ ] kidding me you know like
that's another example of a guy who who
like went from you know three years ago
people are like oh I've seen him he's
funny to just like oh yeah he's playing
a juggernaut you know he's doing he's
doing a five nights at the uh Aloha
Arena or you know whatever you know
where it's just like same thing with Tom
where they they just
built their own thing they built their
own stadium well that's the beautiful
thing is that no longer is it just
Netflix or just HBO right it's your own
YouTube It's Amazon it's show time it's
all these places there's so the good
news is if you have fans and they like
you there's no uh Channel loyalty right
you know what I mean they're gonna
they're gonna put your name in a search
engine and [ __ ] find you and they're
like they don't give a [ __ ] if it's
Pluto TV exactly what I mean they don't
give a [ __ ] if they love you yeah and
I'm just trying to get more people to
know who who would like me to know who I
am that's that's all I'm kind of doing
right now which is you know it's fun
it's fun to feel a little a little more
free I remember uh uh canane uh what
last year the the last
uh just for laughs before the lockdown I
was like hey hey how was you know and
I've done it probably nine times and
stuff and I'm sure you've done it a
bunch of times and and no you really
this was my first year seriously yeah
that makes no sense to me yeah me you're
one of the funniest guys I know all
right anyway but I was like how's it how
was it this year and Kyle was like
dancing for the Empire has become
tiresome
and it is because that's how they make
you feel and that Festival has been good
to me you know what I mean but it is
that thing where it always you just feel
like all eyes are on you and they're not
you know uh but you you feel all kind of
you tense up and I feel like those guys
and gals do it being Pioneers that you
know doing their own thing making these
podcasts massive and stuff and blowing
up on social anyway
Brave New World pretty cool all right so
let's get into your story okay so uh
2020 you know we're all we're locked
down uh my wife and I had a kid uh and
um we uh she was born in August and and
so we're um
you know gearing up and we we did the
hospital thing with you know she had our
daughter with a mask on I had a mask on
um it was a wild wild time uh the whole
thing broke my brain at one point
because at one point you guys I I know I
say we were you and your wife was
pregnant when there wasn't covet that's
right and then all of a sudden the last
like it seems like maybe the first half
of the pregnancy was no covet exist and
then march on it's holy [ __ ] yeah I
remember I never forget uh sitting with
her on the porch and her realizing where
everyone is just Dawn and everyone like
they we can't fly in for the baby shower
and she's like I'm not gonna have a baby
shower and like just started crying and
I just it just broke me in half because
it was like and but that was
extrapolation of everyone everyone had
something that they were gonna looking
forward nope you know I can't understand
my producer was gonna get married and it
ruined them I mean ruined what they had
planned to do they still went and did
them so glad they didn't go that bad
ruin the marriage
well their original plan he turned gay
what I don't
I don't know if you can believe that I
don't know he can't blame me
yeah I mean it was it was it was uh at
one point I went to get coffee uh when
we were there for the hospital for three
days because you had to show up on your
due date if you even if you're having a
kid or not you know we had to go and get
it get induced oh is that right yeah
there was no oh well it's coming when
it's coming oh yeah they were like nah
we got your spot yeah yeah you don't
want your spot it was like a restaurant
yeah yeah like you don't show up by
eight we're gonna give that table away
it was like that and so I I went to get
coffee like the second day and I came
back and went in the wrong room and
there was a dude in his and his lady and
they were feeding the baby she has no
shirt on titties out and I just walked
in coffees I was like oh my God I'm so
sorry they relaxed so hard
they're always they're like always
remember remember when that ding bat
yeah
titties were all out and [ __ ]
TV right she didn't give a [ __ ] I was
like it's a moment
you know him he's the guy that got mad
tv canceled
that him
I think I saw him Pushing Daisies uh but
like yeah so it was a Banana's time so
we go home and it was just you just live
at home and it was perfect because you
know they have this kid I'm just taking
care of this kid she doesn't have to
work this point and
um we were like got this wild idea of
why don't we uh my parents drove down in
an RV that they rented for one weekend
and came in the house tested and all
that jazz and then it was like cool but
like then we were like well let's let's
uh let's let's go up there and uh
uh Oregon caught fire
and then so where's up there uh Portland
Oregon so you're trying to drive up to
Portland yeah I was playing fire I mean
all of Oregon along the Route wildfires
in Scotland everything yeah yeah it was
back the air quality was was worse than
um industrialized areas of India where
they don't have environmental
regulations to the degree we have and
it's just like it's it's like being it's
like smoking all day yeah and so uh
we're like we can't take this kid up
there I don't want to go up there it's
brutal and so as I put it California
then got jealous and it caught fire too
and you remember that yeah and so the
wildfires were real close especially on
the east side of uh of Greater Los
Angeles and we were just like what if we
just drove to your house your parents
house in uh in Mansfield Massachusetts
about 3 300 miles so original plan
Portland yeah and then back to
California and nah none of that so let's
just go all the [ __ ] way get the [ __ ]
out of Dodge judge and just take this uh
small brand new baby yeah six weeks
and load uh this car up like a like a
like a the end of a Tetris game like so
all this [ __ ] and just and and drove
there lived there for uh a month all
right wait how long did it take you oh
God a week probably about a week and you
have a new baby it was the scariest
thing you encountered driving with a new
baby across the country
you know what because it was that time
of ramp and covid where
you know I've had covet at least I've
had it once definitely I feel like I
might have had it twice I've had it
twice yeah
um I'm not walking around like I'm
immune you know but uh at the at the
same time I I don't get that feeling
walking to a crowded room I used to
right be like no no no
I I really felt like you know because we
just say we just got takeout everywhere
but I remember waiting for takeout in a
packed Cracker Barrel and and being like
you got to take this baby outside yeah
put this baby in the car right now yeah
I'll take the hit I would do that on a
normal time
[Laughter]
you know what I'm saying like no and
they'll call us it was it was like being
in another world where like you know
people uh from you know New York or
California or Oregon so is it like
they'll go down south and they'll be
like everyone's acting like there's no
covet here and stuff yeah sure that's
everywhere and we're comedians we've
always kind of been in these areas that
just like the rules don't apply to us
and he's like I can I can dig
libertarian Lifestyles for foreign
like the staff was so happy and [ __ ] and
they were just it was just they were
that whole thing of like it'll get here
when it gets here yeah I don't know I
think they made it I don't want to go
check it you're just like I didn't get
the [ __ ] like I was scared I was like I
need to get out of here I have a child
please you know and we're in a motel it
was just down the road and it was like
like I don't know if that was actually
you know what no
I remember the scariest was when because
we drove through the Deep South
on the way back all right the week of
the election
the week of the election
and uh we were in oh
we're in Mississippi
yeah
that's right that is the sound that's
the South here and um people hear my
accent are you from the south I'm like
no Maryland is not the sound no it is
not it is below the Mason-Dixon line but
it's like the [ __ ] South there's but
only a couple of seconds it's kind of
honorary North let's be honest you know
would you if you're like if you're like
oh that salt that southern city
Baltimore you're like no not enough your
mind yeah Mississippi yeah yeah and I
will say what are you driving uh uh a
Tesla black Tesla okay California plates
right yeah it's Target definitely
oh yeah you know what I mean it's like
some some of the charging stations I'm
just like there's gonna be a guy your
car's got a mess
with an AR just waiting no shirt on like
sure I got one just a turkey shoot you
know especially if you remember the
tension during that week oh [ __ ] that
tension when
you know they're like stop the count and
because because all the all the vote by
males hadn't come in and they're like
rampaging going to the election counters
and screaming and banging on the windows
and stuff like I didn't see any of that
all I will say all that wildness you
know I don't want to be that guy who's
just like it's the media but like
here's the thing it's social media it's
all clicks and it always has been even
before we had social media so before the
news leads the leads 100 yeah so it's
like when there was the riots in
Portland which was just people would
March and then late at night a couple
people would set [ __ ] on fire and that
I'm not that's [ __ ] but if you were
there and I had friends there they were
just like
yeah there was there was tear gas and
stuff like that but it's like it's a
it's not constant rioting this is just
not to be like a few bad apples but you
know it's like but if you watch the news
especially like Fox News like I had I
had friends that live in in Florida they
were you know uh Texas that were just
like so how are your parents man I'd
hold her whole City's on fire and you're
like it's a
four block radius yeah right everything
else no like you no don't believe the
hype kind of thing so
I met more people that were just content
to be like hey how you doing you know
what I mean because the south is is also
polite that's the thing people forget
you know when they when they when they
uh uh stereotype it just like anywhere
else
um but people like I had one time where
I was at the I'm charging my car and
this where uh how do you do it in a
place like Mississippi dude I man they
have them everywhere oh is that right I
mean everywhere wow I've been in the
most rural area and I'm like and they
just there's one out by you know because
I think they made a deal with like
Walmart and Target so they'll have them
in their parking lots you know and yeah
I think it was a park at uh a Target
parking lot and it had all these other
uh restaurants and things I think a
Cracker Barrel this let's have this
episode be sponsored by Cracker Barrel
you're listening Cracker Barrels uh
reach out uh love your chicken fried
steak uh and and this dude like in a
pickup like like
rolls up and he gets out and he had no
shirt on like none and just he had the
kind of if if you if you told somebody
what Bert Kreischer looked like
and they were kind of like oh he sat and
and you're also like this is how much he
drank this week
it's typical week that would you know
you draw him because like Bert's in
decent shape yeah he's got a belly he is
but it's one of those hard bellies you
know what I mean it's like a tough belly
this guy had a real soft belly like one
of those bellies where I remember I went
to Arthur Bryant's barbecue in Kansas
City once and there was a guy who's
probably like barely 30 but was so fat
and so pink he looked like an actual Pig
and I was I was afraid for him as he's
just inhaling ribs and I'm like please
please slow down sir please stop you
know like did you ever smoke cigarettes
no thank God no well I
I used to smoke when I drank and it was
like I was gonna say you ever have
someone try to bum one of your smokes
off you that you're like I don't think I
can man yeah you're terrible these are
terrible your skin looks awful and your
frame is not built for all that weight
so this guy gets out and it's just like
he has these he has these jeans that
look like a denim tent that someone took
deep into the woods for a long time I
think he had one flip-flop flop on one
one flip yeah just huge gut and he gets
out and he's just kind of he's just like
looking at me but he's almost looking
through me and I can't tell if he's
drunk or what this is an alien to him
right now yeah and I I just got out of
my car and I probably look like I'm
alone you know so he's just like what's
up with you man and but then I go around
the side of the car and I take out rows
now rose has a giant head of curly hair
she looks like Darla from Little Rascals
I'll be honest and she was just starting
it but she has these she has like these
eyes that look like sapphires nobody in
my family has blue eyes same with uh my
wife except for her mom and my mom like
there's I think she has a couple of
different relatives all my everybody in
my family
it has has dark eyes so I pull out this
black Irish baby dark curls bright blue
eyes just pull her out and he goes from
I'm gonna murder you with my hands
two
like I just saw I saw his musculature
relax
and he just said
to this day I don't know if he was
talking to me
or God but he just went
oh
look at that baby
how was it look at that baby and he said
it again like under his breath it was
almost like a song you know like a
southern guy has like a a little tone
that flows oh look at that baby that
changed that man yeah like Elvis sound
like a kind of like an Elvis riff and
then I think that guy was was Leonard or
something is Leonard
yeah oh no no
yeah let's just say it was he was like
he's like Leonard he goes look at this
like he yelled it and his friend got out
of the car oh somebody in there yeah and
the guy got out and looked and there did
well just stand there and we just
started talking
and he's like is it and again and they
were just like the guy's like what's
that spaceship you know is that a tall
yeah yeah yeah it's a tall it's a tall
sound
Oklahoma yeah and it just went all
tension gone I mean I kind of feel like
we just we defuse so many situations we
just brought our kids just bring your
kid along to any kind of mixed group you
know uh Viewpoint wise it's just kind of
like look we all want the same thing
deep down like come on you know like
let's just get there and so I ran into
like we were in we were in uh in New
Orleans when they called it for Biden
called it and it was like it was like
kind of like being in like a uh I almost
want to say a
like a a blue Alamo where like uh you
you get through like you get through the
gates just as the Cavalry was about to
murder you the other Army you know but
at the same time I think it was just
this was before Trump was doing his
whole they stole it from me right right
it was just every Network's calling it
and we're not hearing from either one of
these guys and so you saw people either
bumming or losing their mind with joy
you know or just smiling you know like
nobody that's one of those things I
would think about the manipulation that
we're subject to as as human beings and
US specifically As Americans is like
there was no one losing their [ __ ] you
know it was like it's like there were
people partying in bars and stuff but
like they weren't you know what I saw
cars with Trump stickers go by and you
know I think maybe once I was someone
was just like like haha or something
like that but like that was I saw it
once and I was in the South I saw a lot
of those trucks and I didn't see any
anyone you know [ __ ] with those guys
I mean in fact we got we parked and we
got uh I I opened the trunk and I'm we
had this like baby station back there
specifically marked off for diaper
changing so I put her down and this dude
walks by
it just looks like he came out of a
shack and he's got a red wagon with like
three kids in it
and he has a t-shirt on that's like
shredded but he took he took he had a
paintbrush and he painted by dawn like
across the whole front and he's dragging
he walks by his like she's gonna grow up
in a better world
you walk by oh but it was like it was it
was it was cool to be in that town where
it was just like I you know you're
you're from you are you from Baltimore
yeah yeah so you like a nice cultural
mix I'd imagine right yeah I mean I'm
not a fan of black girls if that's what
you're asking that's exactly what I
meant sure yeah
you like black chicks right
look at that
give the gift of dad grass this holiday
season now available for everyone in the
family dad mom even the dog you and your
loved ones can chill out without getting
them stoned to the bone that grass is
legal organic hemp that relaxes your
body and Mellows your mind that grass
CBD products are made with 100 organic
hemp that's easy to dose and the effects
come on smooth they offer a variety of
products from their smokable pre-rolled
joints which are my favorite as well as
hemp flower and a variety of CBD
tincture drops enjoy the effects of CBD
while keeping a clear head all bad grass
products are federally legal for ages 18
and over and it ships right to your door
anywhere in the U.S whether you're
looking for a new Buzz or a chill way to
enjoy an old favorite that grass will
leave you in a euphoric mood go to
daggrass.com honeydew to check out their
products right now dad grass is offering
my listeners 20 off your first order
when you go to daggrass.com honeydew go
to daggrass.com honeydew for 20 off your
first order that's daggrass.com
honeydew you've heard me talk about how
important it is to have a VPN to protect
your online privacy but choosing a VPN
you trust is equally as important I only
recommend Brands to my listeners that I
believe in and I can say with full
confidence that expressvpn is the best
VPN on the market and here's why number
one expressvpn doesn't log your activity
online lots of Cheaper free vpns make
money by selling your data to
advertisers but expressvpn doesn't do
this they even developed a technology
trusted server that makes their VPN
servers incapable of storing any data at
all number two speed expressvpn now uses
lightweight and new VPN protocol they
engineered to make user speeds faster
than ever expressvpn is always blazing
fast and lets me stream videos in HD
quality with 0 buffering but what really
sets expressvpn apart is how easy it is
to use you don't need any technical
skills to get set up you just fire up
the app you tap one button to connect
that's it even your grandparents can do
it and it's not just me saying this CNET
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals rate expressvpn the
number one VPN in the world I tell you
we have it here at the studio we all use
it so protect yourself with the VPN that
I use and Trust use my link
expressvpn.com honeydew today and get an
extra three months free on a one year
package that's
expressvpn.com honeydew visit
expressvpn.com
honeydew to learn more now let's get
back to the deal okay so wait you let's
go back to the story because you drove
across and you stay there uh yeah your
your in-laws your your wife's parents or
you get your own place no no no we
stayed in their house we all stay in
their house
and then what how long are you there a
month just one month live like townies
and then you're driving back yes right
after that okay uh-huh yeah so we were
there from we left and what'd you do go
down like the east coast and then across
or did you sort of die like kind of
diagonal down okay
um so yeah the night before we were the
the night of the election we were in
oh God damn it what's that uh really
awesome Town
um is it outside or in the Ozarks
compare
God damn it I think the thing that
sticks out my mind is like Steve Martin
lives there all these people live there
that it's it's like a lot of bands have
come out of there
butchering someone's screaming at me
right now listening to this podcast and
they know exactly what but it was like
one of those like really
mixed towns like New Orleans It's Not
Branson Missouri no okay no it's I keep
wanting to say uh Raleigh but it's not
it wasn't Raleigh okay
um
God damn it
uh uh yeah it'll it'll I'm gonna we'll
have to edit the same or something in
the middle of [ __ ] night tonight
exactly of course it will of course well
but my point is there were uh you know
it was the night it was the night of the
election and I just went and got take
out and I got to go cocktails for me and
the wife and was like all right like
let's let's then I'm watching you know
the Returns come in and down below us
there are people coming in from the
rural areas with like Trump flags and
honking and people and like and it was
that that was when I saw people
screaming at each other kind of thing
these guys were just kind of like
rabble-rousing and uh uh and doing that
like just kind of like riling up the
hippies we're just like dude why you
know but it was such a [ __ ] crazy
time to not be in my house you know
because like in LA when they called it
people were partying at gas stations and
[ __ ] I'm just like I wouldn't I wanted
to be around that Vibe man that'd be
cool you know but it was like
we were just we were just out there we
didn't really think about
where we would be along the process it
was more you know when you focus on the
more important things like your family
you're kind of just like well look we're
gonna get there when we get there and
this is the best
you know way possible like the only time
we ever really pushed it
in terms of the the trip was when we
tried to we drove from um Erie uh
Pennsylvania to Buffalo and that was
like and that was a last leg and it was
already Nightfall and that was like one
of those like they're a couple times
where I was freaked out but she we got
her that right time we could never do
that right now she's two now no no she
would never stand for that those like
long right no way baby no sleep sleep so
much they you know like and and uh she
realized as we were driving a buffalo
like it hit her like I should I should
be in a bed this is this is horseshit
and she just started crying like so
[ __ ] loud it was just that thing
where I'm just like pedal to the metal
please cops don't don't stop me you know
but driving into it's one of those
things I don't regret at all because
just the the the sanity it gave us as
parents and as people who do like to
travel and and and and and see other
people and you know not really see other
people I'm trying to get my wife to
agree to that but you know right no just
like it was it was the the best thing
for me you know that that's one of those
things like when your producer told me
like oh you know you could bring in like
your kind of dark darker low low uh
points in your life kind of thing
I already brought mine in that last one
I did with you where I talked about you
know going you know to my drunk as [ __ ]
to my current wife's first wedding you
know yeah I remember right and it was
like and that era in that year of my
life where I was just like I would have
I done with myself what the [ __ ] am I
kind of thing where it's like this is
this is this is like a high that had
moments of holy [ __ ] [ __ ] like what's
going on you know what's going on in the
country what am I doing but it was also
like
I I use this quote a lot but you know
it's I do think Helen Keller nailed it
she's like safety is basically an
illusion life is either a great
adventure or nothing like you really you
have to go for it
remember I was talking just the truth I
was talking to Joe Coy about that about
like how but I'm just thinking just
gotta go reach for the iron
we're talking about our dreams like
she's just like I just wanna [ __ ]
well you know you know she said that to
a guy after he was like why'd you grab
my dick like that's what that's how
that's you didn't know that story no
Helen Helen Helen went for it man hell
and wheels I heard she would she would
say to do she'd be like you sure cocking
I can't tell and just grab them just get
it just get up just get a piece of that
kielbasa right away and yank it that's a
good quote though that's a real quote
though it's a real quote it's a real
quote about how where people like how
did you make it through this how did you
what about your journey and she's like
you just you kind of have to say [ __ ] it
and it's like
you know I there were several times on
this trip I'm like we could die I don't
know what's going to happen what were
you what was most scary for you because
you also have a newborn you have a
newborn Yeah well yeah exactly it wasn't
so much we could but
you know it it comes down to this is
this is the only thing that matters to
me is this kid you know what I mean I
have to keep this kid alive or or I will
die I will die I can't go on without
this kid so uh there were times where
you know not worried for the the kids
safety but just like you know [ __ ] goes
wrong crazy stuff happens on the open
road we live in LA where people just
shoot each other from from Cars because
they got each other off and stuff and
like you know I didn't know like I
thought like you you were like did you
have a charging station everywhere
there's ones like in the jungle in the
desert like they're all over the place
yeah I didn't know I didn't know how
they built that infrastructure it was
before that whole bill they just passed
and
you know I I worry I I you know you see
stuff on the news about guys you know
parking their giant pickups in front of
them
[ __ ] you yeah totally uh saw none of
that everybody was was you know there
were that they're a lot more stalls open
in Mississippi I'll say that you know
yeah but like I met a I met a dude in
Alabama with a with a uh F-150 most
popular vehicle in America and uh he was
he had he had a Tesla too and he was
charging his Tesla and he pulled up in
his F-150 and his wife got out of the
Tesla and they switched cars and uh he
was like he's like I'm not doing
anything I'll just stay here while I
draw charges and um and we just started
talking about about Parenthood and he
said because your daughter's how old
this will be eight eight right on and um
he he told me he's like he's like having
daughter's the best he's like you know
they love your guts so they're 13 then
they hate the [ __ ] out of you to the 30
and I'm like wow 30 is a long time
that's a long time home for 25. right
yeah post College
I don't know if we'll be alive I had her
late long time me too a long time
I don't want to be my deathbed and she's
like you're okay now yeah you know what
you know what you're all right yeah yeah
I don't get anything other than that
yeah no
but yeah it was it was
this this this journey of just
experiencing different uh uh
environments that were oddly very
similar in their own way you know what I
mean yeah I agree I think most people
want the same [ __ ] I think yeah I think
really when it comes down to uh gun laws
most people either side want the same
[ __ ] thing Common Sense
yes I mean of course I don't care who
you vote for most people want that most
people want the same thing when it comes
to yeah I'd say money and all that [ __ ]
it's when it's when the teams start
railing each other up and everybody gets
this and all it also you could take 12
videos and put them out online and be
like look at all these people blocking
the Chargers and it's 12 people oh yeah
out of billions yeah you know what I
mean so it's not a real representation
when you do the math it's not a real
representation of anything can you
imagine if we did that about more [ __ ]
where it's just like it seemed a
gentlemen or or take out their dicks in
Walmarts and um
[ __ ] and [ __ ] Halloween uh uh
decorations right in the aisle and they
found they found one guy doing it and
it's just like it's it's a thing people
are doing and of course since we have
one guys one guy one guy people are
pulling their penis out Walmart
but if you do hashtags
send a pic
blur out the stuff
you're gonna hang up your Halloween
decorations and your kids like oh I love
Halloween and your neighbor's like put
that take that down someone's gonna [ __ ]
that someone's gonna go farther take
down that fake witch
oh man
so let me ask you this what is something
you learned about your wife on this trip
that you didn't know already about her
this is a lot of time in close quarters
with a brand new human yes that you both
have to keep alive sure who just came
out of her body P.S you still feel the
same yeah you're [ __ ] [ __ ] is fine
yeah man your pussy's fine Titan right
right yeah
so what is something you might maybe the
same thing what is something you guys
learned about one another that you
didn't already know well I had well we
had a um a snoo you know what snow is it
is uh basically a crib that kind of
rocks the child you strap them in it's
like full-on like a baby uh uh straight
jacket and and it and it makes a a sound
that simulates the wounds it's like a
white noise okay so it's dope if you're
in the room with it too it makes you go
to sleep and this [ __ ] thing weighs
uh as much as you and I had to put it in
a different hotel room every night every
night for at least a week each way and
as I mentioned tetrising the whole back
so like Snoop put something to Snoop put
that in and all this Jazz and so I had
to you know in different hotels or like
luggage cart
you don't have that yeah right and so
I'd like I would get a a laundry Barrel
whatever you call them and put that
[ __ ] in there and stuff so I was in
she was always in charge of just putting
the kid in and and doing that I was like
the mule I always carried all the heavy
stuff
um so that wasn't surprising to either
one of us but uh I I was
I'm always surprised at how she can just
be kind of she can just be in like cool
under like if if some Clerk's being a
dick or whatever where you know I think
someone someone like Snapped at her and
she's like holding a child we just been
driving for like eight hours and she was
just like okay I understand that kind of
thing where I'm just like
I would be so mad if someone did that I
think I would take my child and hit them
with my like take her head you know take
her feet in the face but it was like she
it just she could just do that but I
will say I mentioned this on the special
that like I'm one of those people who I
liked the fact that supposedly they
don't start start absorbing
words and things until you know
well you know maybe like I don't know
I'm not gonna say exactly what it was
but it was like months in and she was
only weeks
um but my wife was very like and I'd be
just driving and be just like you know
[ __ ] you God damn it go to hell you know
all that stuff he cut me off I'm just
like look at that son of a [ __ ] you
know just angry so it's cursing [ __ ]
and like
you know I look back and I see Rose like
like the taking it in like this is good
I'm drinking this in and my wife
um was always like you you have to
please stop cursing in the car and I was
like you're right I need to but then I
flashed back on the amount of times on
the trip where we slept in the same room
as her every single night every single
night so that's every single night in
those hotel rooms I gotta piss it's just
to Jewel Heist every time yeah just
going slow like [ __ ] don't hit the
lasers you know and don't step on
anything creaky or a toy and scream you
know
um and so she's in the same room as us
and like my my daughter would wake up
like at like five sometimes you know she
used to wear a middle of the night get
fed put her back and then but you know
we'd hope she'd sleep until six or
something she'd wake up like in number
one one time she woke up at like 4 30 in
the morning and my wife loud as I'm
about to say it now just goes this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
how could she not hear that yeah she's
clearly not asleep you know but she also
like at one point uh I was I had no
shirt on and I was picking her up and
she was going for my nipple and I was
like no no no wrong parent no milk comes
out of this one and my wife is brushing
her teeth and she steps in the room and
goes just jizz
like what if that sinks in you know what
if that comes out so man you can't watch
everything you say no no absolutely not
I had a guy one time I was you know when
I was moved in with my daughter she was
one so I'm a new dad new single dad I
don't know anything I'm using doordash
because it's called doordash they're
gonna bring it to my door that's right
okay not to the door of my building
they're gonna bring it to my door right
this one guy it's only been one and I've
used it a ton this Russian dude all
pissed off he's like he calls me he's
like there's no Park and I'm like yeah
there is just pull up out front throw
your hazards on and just run it up real
good no you come and bring me the food
I'm like I would but I can't I'm up here
with a one-year-old and I got too much
going on I'm not grabbing her to bring
her down right I'm paying you and tipped
you well to bring this to my door you
come down and get it you don't tell me
what I saw I said listen [ __ ]
and I went I did I went I went zoned in
and I was like it's called doordash it's
in the [ __ ] name you
I'll cancel you I said that throw the
[ __ ] order away I don't care to hung
up my phone and I turned around I was
like
oh yeah my daughter's here and she's
sitting on the couch and she goes
even though if it was good or bad that's
so good
people like yeah you give it to him I
was like oh don't don't do that that's
not a good thing and then he brought it
up
no way yeah and I I I my daughter thinks
nothing is funnier than when I I I yell
in anger or if like like not when I'm
really she you know she can divide but
it's like it's a joke where she'll
she'll go behind a door and like shut it
off Rose yeah
and she's just cackling like these
things it's the funniest or if I I'll
pretend to fall on the couch and go ah
like I'll do a blood curdling scream and
just fall and she's just like slapping
her knee cracking up so it's like if I
ever actually scream at her like in
actual Rage which I've never done okay I
mean when she's a teen probably but or
fall down and actually scream in pain or
hurt myself like she's gonna be laughing
yeah it's gonna be like on a cellular
level but she'll have funny it is funny
and seeing someone trip up steps yeah
and try to catch themselves
yeah dude I I had a bit about when I I
when I was a waiter uh or a food Runner
I did this this guy this smaller guy was
who's real [ __ ] like the head food
Runner you know we there we'd loaded up
this tray with way too many things and
he was just and he comes back he's like
who's who's that and we're like no we
didn't want to say don't do it you know
he's like my it's mine we're like and he
lifted you could see in his eyes like I
[ __ ] up and he got it above his head
he's like goes out and it's a whole
story where it goes he trips and the
[ __ ] goes everywhere but uh a plate hit
a dude in the face and he made a noise
like oh
and it was like I felt so bad but that's
the weird scream you make when you're
you know because man we all have this
wave go oh like a manly way of hurting
but he did this yell that like I compare
it to like when I look back like that
that slip people like when people slip
in ice so bad they go into the air yeah
they go no and then it's still got them
on the way there yeah and all they think
about is that womanly scream they let
out in the air like it's so embarrassing
but it's so funny to hear it you know I
mean I think that's one reason Will
Ferrell said has such a massive career
because he was a giant guy who would
scream in pain and fear hilariously not
that any giant guy can just do it but
it's like yeah that was the key that was
what made us all dig that guy because it
just makes everyone if you scream in a
man voice
it's comedy gold it just uh it just did
like I feel like your mom's house was
was built on clips of dudes horribly
injuring themselves oh Tom just laughing
laughing his ass on that show a couple
times I'm just like I can't look at this
man yeah there's [ __ ] he shows me I'm
still traumatized I'm not even kidding
you I've watched I've watched egg yolks
go up people's [ __ ] I'm like why
aren't you giving me a disclaimer bro
like what and then it comes out and they
eat it I'm like stop
stop
stop
a
a friend in a friend in Chicago he he
had this one like pillow that he would
like watch football land on and just rub
on his knots and like it just you know
like on his couch and just sweat through
it and stuff and like
we wore over in this guy it might it
might have been my then girlfriend it's
my friend my friend Henry he's like he's
like oh my God this smells just like
cinnamon she goes it does no
[Laughter]
[Music]
nothing smells worse than balls and it
was just uh
it's like a Yankee Candle that just is
called balls
um so how are you doing with being a
parent how's it affected your marriage
good well
yeah because the way you are yeah
I'm fully dug now I mean are you guys
closer now than ever are you working
good as a team yeah tell me what that
feels like because I don't know I'm
sorry it's okay tell me no it's it's
good because we're like old parents you
know she's 41 I'm 48 Okay and like uh
yeah I for for me this is one of those
things I never thought would happen what
being a dad or married or what do you
mean kind of both yeah married I could
see more but like how long you've been
married uh since 28 five years okay uh
and so it just it's one of those things
I just didn't
I I thought that that that door had
closed and uh yeah I was just like I
don't see this I don't you know one of
those things where if it ever occurred
to me I was like well that's that's not
happening kind of thing uh and so you
were always if it happens it happens you
remember I want to be a dad and never
opposed to being that's exactly right I
was always like if I'm with someone that
I love enough and they really want one
then we'll have one and that's what
happened and it's been the best thing
possible for me yeah where I'm healthier
I have way better perspective you know
when you recognize really what matters
and how you know this business is so
[ __ ] stupid the way it's built
nonsense and it yeah it's there's it's
full of people who are like here's what
you gotta know and they don't know
anything nothing because no one does
it's because the rules are always
changing and the re the only you know
like uh uh Philip Seymour Hoffman and
Almost Famous the only only real
currency in the world is when you're
uncool and it that that includes just
being [ __ ] totally honest and
supportive and all that [ __ ] and that's
a rarity in the in this business like I
think about the movie Grizzly Man
sometimes I never saw it I know the guy
gets live with lives with bears and gets
eaten by bears right but the the one
thing I watched a a a a mini doc about
it or something they talked about it 60
Minutes or something and he supposedly
it was down he was an actor and it was
down to him and Woody Harrelson for the
role of Woody on Cheers no is that right
yeah and remember when they when Woody
came out like cheers was hot cheers
already it was already a big deal
already a coach had to be replaced and
yep yeah that's right and yeah launched
he died yeah and and uh it was just it
was sliced bread it was the biggest
[ __ ] show still is still one of those
shows you can just watch any episode
it's just the writing's fantastic yes
home run home run like every line so
good you hear that theme song If You're
a certain age and you're like oh man
yeah so it's down to him and Woody here
of course we all know what happened
Woody Harrelson got it and is still a
bankable star to this day to this day
it's kind of guy's gonna work till he's
dead this dude you know we've all been
there it's down to you and someone else
this dude was just like I'm just gonna
live with bears yeah that's how bad this
business is yeah like I'm gonna go live
with an apex [ __ ] Predator I'm gonna
live with this thing that nothing hunts
no animals hunt this animal because for
Millennia of evolution this [ __ ] has
held his belt like I'm gonna go live
there with those guys like bananas so
it'll [ __ ] you up and and it definitely
this business did [ __ ] me up I
definitely had the whole as as my buddy
in Chicago Monty would put it uh compare
and despair man you know compare and
despair well you just go well why am I
not here why is this person here and I'm
here why am I not what did I do wrong
who do they know it's just it's
horseshit it makes it makes you spin out
and
I'm funny you're funny Nothing's Gonna
Change that
we if that's what I'm trying to tell you
JFL my first time this year uh it didn't
matter yeah it didn't matter no of
course not you know you couldn't tell me
that 15 20 [ __ ] years ago 100
000 but it didn't matter like then
you've got two years of no comedy clubs
it didn't [ __ ] matter if you put
yourself online it didn't matter that's
right still an audience there yeah it
didn't matter yeah and you've built this
this Empire of yours that's nice of you
to call it yeah you know I'm using the
term loosely thank you man I appreciate
it we got a couple no good time you got
some [ __ ] man you got you've made some
[ __ ] and and haven't and have a a a a
good and honorable and hilar a name that
means funny you know what I mean so
thank you I'm sad
yeah it's one of those things where
we've already defined ourselves we've
already done that you know and proved
ourselves and well I know if I'd have
pitched this show to anyone they'd have
said no yeah why right no one wants to
hear that we don't want to hear people's
worst times it's all about the
highlights do you own some IP anything
from Marvel do you know yeah right yeah
yeah you know and and it's just anyway
long story long having Rose made me go
okay this is something I'm I'm focused
on I mean and now I'm like I'm that dad
you know I [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah bro I got a rose all mine you
do right there oh [ __ ] yeah let's kiss
you find out it's fake and I'm gay I I
it's a temporary tattoo like this son of
a [ __ ] and then you're pretty mine
almost maybe you're producer you produce
what's your name again Kirsten Kirsten
is like she's telling the story a month
from now and bronkers [ __ ] grabs him
he won't let him go he's kissing him I
had to call the cops the cops [ __ ]
horrible
it was horrible no but yeah it's just
it's just it's it's made uh everything
runs smoothly because it's just you you
can't you can't be selfish and you feel
so much better not being selfish we're
just like I'm gonna I spent all morning
trying to cheer her up you know because
she wasn't feeling that great before I
took her to daycare and got her in the
car and she's kind of crying a little
bit about something and I do this
routine that where I come out of the
house like a dinosaur that's lost and
I'm just like tripping over branches and
[ __ ] and and bushes out in front of my
house and like she is cracking up in the
car and it's one of those things where
I'm just like that to me what's better
than that nothing nothing that'd be like
it'd be like selling out seven nights at
the Chicago Theater or something and
crushing everything nothing it's just
nothing I'm always gonna have so [ __ ]
this business yes and do what's best for
you and your family let's get married
and start a farm
all the way Farm to Table I've been
saying this for years one's wrong or
gonna come around bro Farm to Table I
would be the worst farmer ever over
you're The Gather I'll be a hunting
gather you can be home with the kids oh
that's cool all right great yeah we'll
work it out I'll be a little messy
um
it is the best choice it's the best
thing to do it's [ __ ] all these jobs I
don't care what your occupation is
anymore your family's first yeah you
know what we all just went through and I
you know I don't know if it'll be 10 15
20 years but there'll probably be
another weird lockdown in our lifetime
sure at some point sure at some point we
should be ready for that yeah but uh and
you know what I think is you and I I
mean you had your your your first child
when you were
well I'm 49 that's a 41-2 right so you'd
lived yeah and I'm not saying everybody
have a kid in your 40s but sure as hell
worked for me yeah you know I had tried
everything I mean these needs done it
all back are and not in full agreement
or no the child in my 40s that's true
but everything else has been awesome
yeah yeah yeah but like it just
it's that thing where I really think not
to throw it back to Doug but the reason
why Doug was such a bitter [ __ ] who
worked in finance or whatever [ __ ]
he did uh who's drunk all the time and
hated his wife and kids
and and really what is worth anything in
life if that's where you're at you know
I don't care how much money you have
you're missing right you're miserable
you're miserable so you know I think
it's because he was just like this is
what you do you get a house in the
suburbs you get a wife you have three
[ __ ] kids I don't want them I don't
want these kids you know it's like I
don't want this time share you only get
one life yeah if you don't want kids you
got to lay down the law you have to and
I would have I would have been like I
don't want to have a kid I have friends
who
got vasectomies before they got married
and were like they don't want one you
know and it's like cool but I really
feel like if Doug would have just like
if you take any message from the the
special you know uh besides don't wear a
tank top to a bar where they pour 151 on
it and light it on fire if you have a
hairy back don't wear a tank top that's
a good [ __ ] it's a real story it's a
Chicago story a dude caught fire did he
really yeah she caught on fire yeah we
put him out with a shitload of coats
the main thing is like is like just be
honest with yourself but what you do and
don't want and don't you know it's like
don't be that bitter [ __ ] who has kids
you hate yeah man like yes listen to
your gut your gut is never [ __ ] wrong
my heart has been in the way my head has
been the way my dick has been in the way
yeah my [ __ ] preconceived notions
have been in the way your gut is never
[ __ ] wrong it's the hardest thing to
listen to It's always right and
everything I've I've gained that is
worth a damn I was always like I don't
know how this is gonna go I can't take
back this decision let's try it I'm all
in I tried it with move in with my wife
I tried it with getting married to my
wife both of those I'd never done I'd
never lived with a woman I dated oh yeah
yeah never wow I'd never I'd never been
married so I can try it the big one once
you have a kid we really can't take it
back you can move out you can divorce
somebody this one's a big one and that
was the best decision I've ever made Go
free you know I'm just saying you know
well thank you for coming on thanks man
and um plug everything again because I
want people to know about Doug the
specialist called Doug uh it's named
after a terrible man but it's a it's a
it's a blast I think you'll really enjoy
it uh I want people to watch this with a
group so it's going to be on on moment
house uh October 6th tickets go on sale
uh at Half Price September 15th then uh
full price September 16th uh like I says
me up
October 6th for two weeks and then it's
gone I don't know what's gonna happen
with it next but that's like that's the
move all right so congrats and thank you
for being here thank you thank you guys
every week as well I really appreciate
everything you guys do Ryan sickler.com
Ryan sickler on all social media we'll
talk to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]